nos piden restar está loca expresión que
se ve amenazadora pero si nos fijamos
bien podremos hacer la resta y
simplificar la a su mínima expresión
para empezar podemos observar que aquí
tenemos cuatro veces la raíz cuarta de
81 x a la quinta menos dos veces la raíz
cuarta de 81 x a la quinta tenemos
entonces cuatro veces algo eso que estoy
encerrando aquí en amarillo y así algo
podrían ser caballos tenemos entonces
cuatro veces algo a lo cual estamos
restando dos veces exactamente ese mismo
algo la raíz cuarta de 81 x a la quinta
la raíz cuarta 81 x a la quinta sí tengo
cuatro de algo si tengo cuatro caballos
y le voy a restar dos caballos me van a
quedar dos caballos o si tengo cuatro de
algo y le voy a restar dos veces algo
voy a terminar con dos veces ese algo y
ese algo es la raíz cuarta
de 81 x a la quinta obtuve ese 2
simplemente restando los coeficientes 4
veces algo menos 2 veces algo es dos
veces ese algo y eso por supuesto menos
raíz cuadrada principal la raíz cuadrada
principal de x quick y ahora lo que me
queda es simplificar los radicales en
este caso extraer la raíz cuarta
mientras que en este caso de aquí
extraer quizá la raíz cuadrada principal
para empezar
veamos si 81 es algo a la potencia
cuarta o se puede extraer un factor de
algo elevado a la potencia cuarta
saquemos los factores primos de 81-81
estrés por 27 27 estrés por 9 y 9 es 3
por 3 tenemos entonces que es tres por
tres por tres por 381 lo podemos
escribir como 3 a la cuarta lo cual es
sumamente adecuado porque vamos sacar la
raíz cuarta de eso y quizá la quinta lo
podemos escribir con el producto déjame
escribirlo por aquí para que no se me a
montones entonces lo que tengo debajo
éste radicales 3 a la cuarta que
multiplica
x a la cuarta por x x a la quinta lo
puedo escribir como x a la cuarta por xy
eso sería lo que tenemos bajo ese
radical
eso sería entonces la raíz cuarta de
tres a la cuarta quizá la cuarta x no
hago a brincar pasos esto sería entonces
la raíz cuarta de tres a la cuarta x a
la cuarta por equis y claro esto
multiplicado por dos y x al cubo puede
escribirse como x cuadrada por x es
decir menos la raíz de x cuadrada por xy
lo escribió así porque x cuadrada es un
cuadrado perfecto ahora como
simplificamos esto de aquí a estas
alturas ya conoces este camino esto es
lo mismo que la raíz cuarta de tres a la
cuarta por la raíz cuarta de quizá la
cuarta por la raíz cuarta de x hagamos
eso entonces cuál es la raíz cuarta de
tres a la cuarta no mejor déjame ponerlo
aquí de manera explícita que lo que
vamos a hacer entonces esto es lo mismo
que la raíz cuarta no la raíz cuarta no
la raíz cúbica la raíz cuarta de tres a
la cuarta
la raíz cuarta de x a la cuarta por la
raíz cuarta de x por la raíz cuarta de x
y por supuesto todo esto multiplicado
por 2 y todo esto de aquí menos la raíz
cuadrada principal de x cuadrada por la
raíz cuadrada principal de x y esto lo
vamos a simplificar como aquí tenemos la
raíz cuarta de tres a la cuarta que es
tres simplemente tres luego la raíz
cuarta de x la cuarta que es x aunque
ahora que me acuerdo no es exactamente
el valor de x queremos la raíz cuarta
principal de quizá la cuarta qué pasaría
si x es negativo no podemos obtener un
valor negativo con una raíz principal
así que sin importar si x es positivo o
negativo queremos que el resultado de
esto sea positivo y eso es precisamente
lo que hace el valor absoluto así es que
la raíz cuarta principal de quizá la
cuarta es lo que vamos a obtener aquí es
el valor absoluto de x el valor absoluto
de x y ahora bueno siempre podría ser el
argumento de que x tiene que ser
positivo porque esto que tenemos aquí
bajo el radical tiene que ser positivo
si queremos que esto sea válido para los
números reales pero bueno sigamos con el
argumento que hemos usado aquí esto
multiplicado por la raíz cuarta
principal de x menos la raíz cuadrada
principal de x cuadrada que por el mismo
razonamiento anterior esto es igual al
valor absoluto de x que multiplica a la
raíz cuadrada principal de x hagamos el
producto entonces estoy aquí es 2 x 3
vuelvo al absoluto de x esto es 2 x 3 es
igual a 6 por el valor absoluto de x por
la raíz cuarta principal la raíz cuarta
principal de x y eso menos el valor
absoluto de x que obtuvimos aquí el
valor absoluto de x por la raíz cuadrada
principal de x y ya no podemos
simplificar más porque si te fijas aquí
tenemos una raíz cuarta y aquí tenemos
una raíz cuadrada son de distinto orden
si tuvieran el mismo orden estas dos
raíces quizás podríamos simplificar aún
más así es que hemos concluido con la
resta y la hemos simplificado plenamente
y si suponemos que esto tiene que estar
definido para números reales tenemos que
establecer que el dominio son las x
positivo
las x mayor que 0 para que estas raíces
estén definidas si las x son mayor que 0
no vamos a estar tratando con números
imaginarios si los valores de x son
positivos entonces podemos asumir que el
valor absoluto de x es igual a x con esa
restricción de dominio podemos eliminar
el valor absoluto